when you take an AP biology exam it is
likely that will include a formula sheet
that will include formulas like this on
it and it can be a little bit
intimidating at first because we're not
used to seeing formulas like this that
involve in fact this is formerly
calculus notation in a biology class but
we'll see in this video is that this
formula is actually just trying to
express something that's fairly
intuitive and something that you
actually don't even need calculus
calculus or even much algebra but then
we'll connect it to this to see that it
all makes sense so putting this aside
let me just ask you a simple question
let's say we're studying a population
and we see that the birth rate the birth
rate of this population is equal to 60
let's say we're studying a population of
bunnies 60 bunnies bunnies per year and
let's say we know that the death rate of
bunnies death rate is equal to 15
bunnies bunnies per year now without
even paying attention to this formula
sheet up there what do you think given
this data is the population population
growth rate for this population of
bunnies pause this video and see if you
could answer that well your population
growth rate if you think about just even
say a given year in that year you'll
grow your population by 60 bunnies per
year so you will grow by 60 bunnies per
year and but then you would shrink by
the 15 that died so it would shrink by
15 bunnies bunnies per year and so in
that year you would net out 45 bunnies
and that's a rate because you're saying
per year so you would grow by 45 bunnies
bunnies in that year and that would be
your population growth rate now the
thing that we just did very intuitively
you don't need advanced math to think
through what we just did that's exactly
what this formula is saying this
notation where you say D something DT
this is the rate at which this something
is changing with respect to time
so this is just a fancy way of saying
what is the rate at which our population
is changing with respect to time there's
other ways that you could have written
that if you didn't want to use calculus
notation you could have brought written
change in population for a given change
in time the Greek letter Delta often
denotes change in and what this form of
says is exactly what we did it would be
the difference between the birthrate
which is the letter B in this formula
the birthrate right over here and the
death rate the death rate is the letter
D in this formula you have it right over
here and that's exactly what we did over
there so it's all very intuitive now if
I were in charge of the formula sheet I
might have expressed it a little bit
different maybe I would have used
notation like this maybe I would have
written in plain English I probably
would have used different notations for
the B and the D to make it a little bit
clearer that those were rates but as you
see from this example it's just trying
to express something very
straightforward and frankly something
that you probably actually don't need a
formula sheet for